[Musik]
in der belgier kaserne in graz wurde mit
dem überflug zwei eurofighter kampfjets
die reform der kommandostruktur
feierlich begangen
durch die zusammenführung von land und
luftstreitkräfte sowie der
führungsunterstützung in ein kommando
wird ein optimales zusammenwirken dieser
teilstreitkräfte für einsätze im in und
ausland erreicht heißt es in einer
aussendung des verteidigungsministeriums
verteidigungsminister mario kunasek
betonte dass die standorte graz und
salzburg erhalten und weiter gestärkt
werden meine aufgabe ist das effiziente
strukturen eines österreichischen
bundesheeres sicherzustellen
die wiederum dem österreichischen
bundesheer die möglichkeit bietet ihre
einsatzaufgaben erfolgreich im sinne der
sicherheit der österreicherinnen und
österreicher zu erledigen
[Musik]